[Music]  Macaulay Culkin takes on quite possibly  his most bizarre role yet a crucified  kurt cobain the 36 year old actor stars  in the new father John misty music video  for total entertainment forever as the  late Nirvana frontman and he definitely  had us doing a double-take  it's me McAuley McAuley is seen being  whipped and nailed to a cross in the  clip pretty weird  turns out he was even part of the  production team that directed the video  one of the video producers Adam Green  revealed to pitchfork the former child  star was quote instantly into being a  part of the project  not gonna lie we're still hoping for  another home alone  you